just doing the most of course I have to
do the most this is the thing what you
don't understand is that as a lady I am
displaying to you that it's very easy to
speak to a man like Andrew Tate as long
as you don't need to step on his toes
and you expect you respect the authority
that he has I'm not gonna sit here and
try and fight against a man that has
done a lot more in my life been in rooms
I haven't been in because he's Andrew
Tate I respect you but I can still pop
my point across okay my point is no but
there is a point of course when you say
but after something you just can't snap
it you said before however it's a point
it's an acknowledgment and then comes
the counter argument because I don't
have to agree with things to speak okay
so my point simply is fine I get that
but at the end of the day the same way
that we have evolved now as a woman I
have evolved I I would expect and what I
do want is not equality is a certain
level of respect which means that if I
am also somebody that is quite smart
somebody that can take care of
themselves I've done all of this for
about 30 years of my life you can't tell
me just no but what the condition is
sorry yeah the condition is instead of
telling me no give me the Assurance as
to why you said no because actually I am
agreeable when you make me feel assured
that what you're doing makes me feel
safe actually because what women are
looking in love for is stability
it doesn't count if you're only
agreeable when you feel like being
agreeable
when you feel like being agree like when
you feel can I just say something out of
respect we live in different houses of
course if I went here never know my me
and my man because I I'm a caregiver if
I if I went he would have never known
right so I still didn't go okay
and
so what you're saying so I'll say to you
okay baby you don't want me to go why
don't you mean to go like what's
worrying what's the matter why would you
not want me to go why would I want to
question him when he's always got my
best interests at home well I want to
know he's not I don't know why because
my best interest why should he have to
explain everything because you're not a
child you are I also want to know
the woman like she doesn't have her own
mind it's very difficult acknowledgment
I'm sorry think about it right I'm a 26
I'm 26 right yeah I've lived my life all
by myself and then I'm in a relationship
and this man is telling me I can't go
out
does that make sense can I do that to a
man and just say I don't want you I told
him if I tell my man listen right you
know you said you're going such and such
well you know what I don't really think
you should go you'll think about it and
he'll say you really don't want me to go
and I'll say no it won't go that's a lie
that's not a lie there's no matter
let me give you let me baby let me ask
your girlfriend let me ask you girls a
question the reason she decided not to
go is because this is obviously not a
regular occurrence right so he had a
reason and she trusts his judgment let
me give you girls a scenario let's
imagine I'm with a chick whatever she
has a concert I say I don't want you to
go and she she replies like you why
can't I go and I say
got a bad feeling don't go now what now
so which would you think the woman
should just go I don't give a [ __ ] about
your stupid feeling and bounce
the memories
listen my sister this is the key when
you say I don't know I just call a bad
feeling let me tell you how that is get
translated into my head he cares about
me and he's actually thinking about
something that potentially could be
happening that I'm not aware of I love
him for thinking outside the box but
you've reassured me you've shown me
respect for being able to provide your
decisions and that's all it takes no
that's all it goes no but I'm sorry but
you've had logical reason as to why
you're going to tell me I feel it I'm
feeling it's not logical bad feeling a
feeling
the whole point
the whole point is a guy doesn't want to
explain like what every decision he
makes
a lot of times like men think things
through a lot like more than we realize
and so he's already thought about it
he's already made his decision it's a
headache to him when every time he makes
a decision he has to explain it to you
that's right man if you trust that man
and you've been with him as long as
Auntie's been with her man and he says
something with the kind of relationship
they have and the respect they have for
each other of course she's gonna be like
all right well cool Don that's trust and
that's trust I wasn't happy of course
and also that's that's a really good
point about submission because
submissions is largely misunderstood
like I can tell you a million stories
I've had girls who are like yeah you're
the man you're in charge and yeah no
problem did uh yeah she's cool and she's
cool on the jet she's cool in Dubai
she's cool in the restaurants she's
cooling the five stars she's cooling the
lambo but the second I say something
that she that she'd half doesn't like
then she's like well you know what that
that's the feminist right so women do
this very well a lot of women flip-flop
like if you trust your man and you
really want to be with him and you
really want to submit to them there's
going to be times you're going to submit
in ways you don't like that's the whole
point of it yeah two things you don't
want to do I'm glad she said this in the
past I respect you in the fact that
you're willing to give a woman a life
you're willing to provide for her so I
respect that you can then tell her I
want you to do this baby but she has to
listen you're right but a lot of women
they they want autonomy over themselves
personally I don't want a man that's
going to provide for me just so he can
tell me to sit down and I'm a dog and
I'm gonna put it down let's understand I
can make my own decisions let's
understand something every man will give
you a life it's just a matter of whether
you're happy with not everybody no no
exactly every man will give you a life
it's just a matter of whether you're
happy with the man the life that man is
capable of giving and this goes back
into the earlier points we were saying
you can find a good man who will work
his ass off and give you the best life
he can possibly give you give you every
ounce of strength inside of him he will
give you all he has you can get that but
if you're gonna wake up and go no I
don't want that life I want that life
well then that comes with problems
this is the cognitive dissonance that
most females operate under where they
sit and go I want that life but I want
him to act like that guy I want the
Nissan and the McLaren you can't have
both what about you need to decide and
there becomes a degree of female
maturity as you said earlier you get to
a point where you're like you know what
maybe all that Glitz and Glam and
[ __ ] is it worth it it's not worth
it you grow up right and and that's
fantastic and you make a different
decision and I'm saying that a lot of
women get to that point the problem is
in the modern world the [ __ ] women did
before they got to that point from 19 to
24
pisses the man off to the point where
he's never going to be as good as he
could be it's different in your in your
world right you man you stick with it
man dig I know plenty of people first
man High School sweethearts the world
was different only 40 50 years ago the
second man they've been married forever
50-year marriages all that shit's gone
and then we have to tie back into all
the other sub points I've made into
you've had a very fun life at your Peak
sexual value from 19 to 24 running
around doing XYZ now you're with this
guy who can't give you the life he knows
you've already lived part of him feels
inferior his status is damaged because
all the [ __ ] you did is on Instagram and
he ain't the one who gave it to you and
now you're expecting a whole bunch of
crap out of him and now when he comes
and works his ass off and manages to
save up and buy a BMW and picks you up
hey I got a BMW you go
yeah I like Mercedes and this is the
point you're missing it's all about the
[ __ ] car it's about something larger
than that it's about making him feel
like he's a man again and that he's in
charge
I'm an autonomous female I can [ __ ] him
like that but you're what are you doing
you're damaging the psyche of the man
who's trying to love you is it worth it
break it down
does loving mean that you listen to what
I have to say and also think about what
I want and not just what you want it's
not about is that what loving means if
that's it I can I can subscribe to that
but I'm not gonna subscribe to you sit
down and you have to sit down grown ass
woman I pay my own bills and you're
gonna tell me what to do that's fine but
it gets to a point it gets to a point
where you have to sit and analyze the
scenario you're in and try and realize
and pick your battles and I'm telling
you you may not realize it but a man
does a whole bunch of [ __ ] for you that
you don't know he's watching the shows
you want to watch He's listened to you
talk gossip about the girls at work he's
[ __ ] going yeah I like that dress
that dress he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
any of it he's doing it for you but the
second is
some [ __ ] issue
yeah he's right because women women talk
nonsense foreign
caters to me I will do anything to make
him happy if he says oh babe I wanna I
like this meal I will I will make sure I
can cook it for him because guess what
he actually cares about what I want as
well you can't just have a one-way
relationship hey I'm just saying
I'm just saying if I was a woman and I
had to make a man as attracted to me as
possible my goal would be to give that
man status and make him feel good about
himself and I'd be very very careful
talking too much about life experiences
or opposing views not because he's out
to oppress me not because he's an evil
horrible person but because he's trying
to find somebody with a similar Life
View he's trying to find somebody he can
show the world to trying to find
somebody can feel like he can teach
things too that's how you get the best
out of a man I'll tell you how I get the
best stuff that's why I got Clementine
no no no but if you go into a man's room
when he's playing video games and he's
playing video games and you say all you
do is play video games then you nag him
he'll play video games if you walk in
there and go you know what you're so
smart I've seen you do so many amazing
things and you've said so many amazing
things why do you waste your time
playing video games you could show me so
much now you're gonna get him off the
[ __ ] console yeah but it's an E I
know it's an ego play I know your old
girls are like why should I have to do
that there's a lot of things it sounds
you look pretty in the morning because
you win it's because in the end you win
you talk about why should I have to do
that well why should you have to work
hard in the gym to get a six-pack
because you win that's the game if you
it's actually men are so simple we are
so simple and the truth is women know it
this is what's amazing women pretend
they're confused you're not confused you
know you're just egos are in the way and
Society is telling you something else
and you just [ __ ] refuse to be
agreeable nice people
why man up this [ __ ] problems
wait wait so I have a question for the
girls so imagine you're dating a guy as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible